. TO ORDER CAN BE CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE DOT DOT HERE
WELL PRESIDENT WELFARE ALLEN
ARCHULETA GORGEOUS. ALLEN
PRESENT ARCHULETA FOR JUST.
BRADFORD. CHANG CHANG HERE
GALGIANI GALGIANI HERE GLAZER
HILL YOUR HILL HERE WEST SO
HERE WHAT'S SO HERE JONES JONES
HERE NIELSEN NELSON HERE
PORTANTINO HERE PORTANTINO HERE
RUBIO. RUBIO HERE WIENER. WE
ARE HERE. ALL RIGHT WE'RE UP
WITH A. B. TEN EIGHTY SIX MISS
ERICA OKAY YEAH CAN YOU STARS
UP THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE BEING HERE TODAY
AND GETTING THE PART OF YOUR
LUNCH TIME CAME HERE WITH AB
TEN EIGHTY SIX A BILL IT'S
FAMILIAR TO ALL OF YOU AB TEN
EIGHTY SIX IT IS DISTRICT BILL
THAT SENATOR GLAZER HAS BEEN
WORKING ON FOR LONGER THAN I
HAVE. AND IT'S BEEN AMENDED TO
CLEAR UP THE AMBIGUITY
AUTHORIZING NOT REQUIRING THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
TO SELL THE ALAMEDA TEST
EXPANSION AREA THE CARNEGIE
STAVING PICULET REACT
RECREATION AREA IF THE SALE IS
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
PUBLIC THE ALAMEDA TESSA PARK
IS A RICH BIOLOGICAL AND
CULTURAL AREA THE SALE OF THE
LAND WERE FIGHT ECOLOGICAL
PROTECTIONS AND ALLOW ALL
VISITORS ACCESS AND ENJOY THE
LAND. AS A BILL STATES THE LAND
SHALL NOT BE SOLD FOR LESS THAN
WITH THE ORIGINAL PURCHASE
PRICE WISE AND PROCEEDS OF THE
SALE SHALL GO TO THE OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE TRUST FUND ALSO
TO NOTE THE BILL IS SILENT ON
IT DOESN'T AFFECT THE CURRENT
OFF ROAD VEHICLE. ARK NEXT
DOOR THE CARNEGIE PARK WHICH IS
CURRENTLY IN OPERATION WILL
CONTINUE TO BE AN OPERATIONS ON
THE STATE PARKS OPERATES IT THE
BILL ENJOYS A BROAD RANGE OF
SUPPORT INCLUDING THE SIERRA
CLUB THE COUNTY OF ALAMEDA EAST
BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT THE
SOCIETY OF AMERICAN INDIANS AND
THE NORTH VALLEY YOU'LL GET
STRIVE. AND NO TAMI. CULTURAL
PRESERVATION. I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION. AND I WILL TURN
IT OVER TO SENATOR GLAZER FOR
HIS COMMENTS. GERMAN NUMBERS
FOR SOMEONE A THANK AT SELLING
WOMAN REBEKAH BAUER QUE HAN FOR
WORKING WITH THE SPEAKER OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE LEADERSHIP TO.
BRING THIS BILL OVER HERE AND
ALLOW US TO HEAR IT AS SHE HAS
SAID WE'VE HEARD IT MANY TIMES
IN THIS COMMITTEE. TWO THINGS
THAT ARE IMPORTANT POINT OUT
AGAIN TO REITERATE ONE IS.
THERE IS CURRENTLY A OFF ROAD
VEHICLE PARK IN OUR DISTRICT.
RIGHT ADJACENT TO THIS PROPERTY
IT'S AN OPERATION NOTHING IN
THIS BILL CHANGES THAT. THOSE
WHO ENJOY THAT SPORT PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO GO TO THIS
SITE AND ENJOY THAT SPORT.
WITHIN A LOCAL CONTROVERSIES
GONE FOR MANY YEARS. CAUGHT UP
IN LITIGATION SURE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS ARE BEING
SPENT ALL THIS BILL DOES IS IF
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS. IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE COMMISSION
DECIDED THEY'VE HAD ENOUGH OF
THIS FIGHT AND THEY DON'T WANT
TO PUSH THIS PROJECT FORWARD
THIS BILL GIVES THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SELL IT FOR
CONSERVATION PURPOSES THAT'S
ALL AN OPTION AND I THINK IT'S
DESERVING OF SUPPORT AND PUSH
IT YOUR CONSIDERATION.
WITNESSES SUPPORT GET OUT UGH.
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON TO BRING
AND ALSO SEE A CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF OUR MORE THAN HALF A
MILLION MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA
MANY OF WHOM HAVE BEEN IN THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND SURROUNDING
AREA FOR. NUMBER OF YEARS
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE WE'D LIKE
TO ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
AB TEN EIGHTY SIX. BOTH OF
THOSE ABOUT THE SENATOR AND
ASSEMBLY WOMAN. SPOKE TO THE
ECOLOGICAL VALUE THAT THIS LAND
HAS BUT I JUST ONE UNDERSCORE A
FEW POINTS ITS LOCATION IS AT
THE INTERSECTION OF FIVE BIOTIC
ZONES. THAT RESULTS IN A RARE
ABOUT DIVERSITY AND SERVES AS A
SPECIES SAVING CORRIDOR AND
BUFFERS IN TIME OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. PRESERVATION OF TESTS
IS UNIQUE RAY OF SENSITIVE A
RARE RESOURCES ARE PRIORITIES
THE CIVIC BEFORE SIERRA CLUB.
AS THEY WERE WHERE ARE FOUNDER
JOHN MUIR. I DID A LOT OF HIS
RESEARCH BACK IN THE DAY.
TUSSLE HOLD FORTY TWO SPECIAL
STATE STATUS WILDLIFE SPECIES
THIRTEEN SPECIAL STATUS IN
TWENTY EIGHT LOCALLY RARE PLANT
SPECIES. AND IF DESIGNATED
CRITICAL HABITAT FOR CALIFORNIA
RED LEGGED FROGS AND ALAMEDA
WITH SIX. THEY'RE SENSITIVE
REAR NECK AND RARE NATURAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES THAT COVERS
NEARLY THE ENTIRETY OF THE TEST
LANDSCAPING CREATE LAYER UPON
LAYER OF AREAS THAT MUST BE
PROTECTED. WHILE WE CAN HAVE
DIFFERING OPINIONS ON WHETHER
NOT OVERREACH WE USE IS A GOOD.
LAND USE WE JUST. MAY WE WOULD
JUST ASK YOU TO NOTE THAT THERE
ARE AREAS WHERE WHICH YOU
SHOULD NOT BE USED. IN THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE. AREAS AND SO WITH
THAT WE ASK YOU TO VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LOOK AT FACTS
ABOUT THE NATURE CONSERVANCY I
GUESS I SEE MY COMMENTS WITH
MISTER OF BRANDON OF THE SIERRA
CLUB BUT I ALSO APPRECIATE JUST
ONE ADDITIONAL POINT YES OF THE
DIVERSITY HOT SPOT BUT IT'S
ALSO. A POTENTIAL PLACE TO FROM
MAJOR CONSERVATION THE BAY AREA
THAT IS WITHIN ABOUT AN HOUR'S
DRIVE ABOUT SEVENTY NINE
MILLION PEOPLE SO IT'S THAT
WOULD BE ANOTHER MAJOR REASON
TO POTENTIALLY I SEE THIS IS
BEING PROTECTED PLACE IN THE
BAY AREA THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BURKE XP HER GOOD AFTERNOON
JAMIE GO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT.
SOCIETY AS WELL AS A LOT OF ON
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THEN
LESS ACCUSED TO REPRESENTING
THE EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK
DISTRICT WE TORRANCE PART
THANKS SO MUCH THANK YOU
WITNESSES OPPOSITION. THE
DISEASE. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TERRY MCHALE WITH
ERIN READ NECESSITY IT'S I
LEARNED HOW TO COUNT A LONG
TIME AGO AND I HAVEN'T
FORGOTTEN SO I WILL KEEP THIS
VERY BRIEF THIS IS THE THIRD
TIME YOU SEEN THIS BILL AND THE
REASON YOU SEEN IT THREE TIMES
IS BECAUSE IT'S A GREAT AUTHOR
BUT IT'S A BAD BILL. AND WHILE
I DON'T EXPECT ANY REAL LEVEL
OF HV I DO UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
IS A PRECEDENT IT'S BEEN
ESTABLISHED HERE THAT PARKS
WENT THROUGH AN ENTIRE PROCESS
IN DESIGNATING THIS IN A WAY TO
BE AREA AND THE PEOPLE WHO
LIVED IN THAT AREA SIGNED OFF
ON IT MANY OF THEM GETTING
RIGHT AWAY AS MANY OF THEM
BENEFITING FROM THE FACT THAT
THIS WAS SATISFIED. WITH H. B.
MONEY FOR AN OHP PURPOSE. IF
YOU VOTE AGAINST IF YOU VOTE
FOR THIS BILL. YOU OF
ESTABLISHED A PRECEDENT THAT IN
YOUR DISTRICT ON MISTER DODD
SENATOR DODD. YOU KNOW YOU MAY
HAVE A BIKE PARK. AND SOMEONE
CAN SAY WE DON'T LIKE THE
RIGHTS THAT ARE BEING LEFT IN
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE STATE
SAID. WE DON'T WANT IT THERE.
IT ESTABLISHES A NEW EXPENSIVE
UNNECESSARY PRECEDENT. THERE
ARE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY PARKS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ONLY EIGHT OF THEM. OR A TREE.
THIS IS AN EXTENSION OF THE
CARNEGIE PARK. I WOULD ASK FOR
A NO VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION BACK TO OTHER
MEMBERS. THE CENTER NIELSEN MR
BUT I'VE FOUND SYMPATHETIC WITH
THE PARKS BUT I'M MORE
SYMPATHETIC THESE DAYS WITH OFF
ROAD VEHICLES. THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ENJOY OFF ROAD
VEHICLE RECORD RATING. HAVE
BEEN RIPPED OFF FOR DECADES THE
MONEY. THE PROJECT. IN THIS
TIME WE TOOK A STAND FOR OFF
ROAD VEHICLES AND THAT'S WHY MY
VOTE WOULD BE NO. THANK YOU.
WITH THE BILL. WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR HILL. ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS. SAYING THAT AND CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE AB TEN EIGHTY
SIX MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DODD I
THOUGHT I WILL. ALLEN. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HYPE
GORGEOUS BRADFORD CHIANG.
GALGIANI HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE BILL HILL AYE WESSEL.
WHAT'S SO I JONES. JONES NOW
NIELSEN NO BILLS AND NO
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO
RUBIO AYE WIENER. WIENER HI.
TENDED TO AND THEN WELL. THAT'S
TEND TO THE BILLS OUT BUT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR TWO OR
THREE MINUTES PEOPLE OUT ON
. IS
THE PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE TENDED
TO ABSENT MEMBERS WILK.
GORGEOUS BRADFORD BRADFORD I
CHIANG. IT'S ELEVEN TO PASS IS